it's great to welcome back to the
program laurie Hodson she's a former
Scientologists of 30 years a
second-generation Scientologist in fact
author of the book a mother's heartbreak
how Scientology destroyed my family
and as Laurie told us last time she was
on she is a second generation
Scientologist was a second-generation
Scientologist she was experiencing
disconnection from her children
and unfortunately Laurie I wish you were
joining us under better circumstances
but the disconnection from the children
which who are still within the church is
not going particularly well is it it's
not it's actually been eight years now
last time I was on with you was four
years so hopefully next year but I
better interview for you and we're all
back together again yeah I hope so
and I mean what so so a lot of people
will hear you know that in the last
interview it had been four years since
you had seen your kids now now it's been
eight years what is actually in practice
what keeps you from seeing your kids in
other words why couldn't you just go and
see them somewhere is it that you're
being kept away are they being kept
somewhere they are not there actually
public Scientologist so they're not in
the see organization anymore I don't
know if they're on staff but if I try to
go see them they're alerted they tracked
my flights and they warned them not to
talk to me so the only way I could get
back to see my children is to go back
into Scientology and do the steps called
A to E I can tell you what those are
real quickly if you want yeah so I mean
I think that would be interesting if you
at this point people might wonder
whether you are so sort of permanently
labeled a suppressive person or whatever
other term might be assigned to you that
so you're sort of beyond redemption as
far as the Church of Scientology is
concerned or if there would be a path
for you to rejoin yes so last summer I
tried to work internally with the church
the only person when you're declared a
suppressive person to talk to is called
the international justice chief his name
is Mike
and I called last summer multiple times
I finally got through to his
receptionist and she told me he never
takes calls and I said well I want to
work out this situation with my children
I want to work with you guys let's work
out a plan well he doesn't take calls
they said well how do I reach them and
they said for me to write a hardcopy
letter which I did and I didn't hear
back for a while and then I got a letter
back and I just asked if we could work
out where I respect them doing
Scientology I won't bring it up and they
can respect me
going back to my baptized religion which
is Lutheran I got a letter back and they
said if you want to get back in good
standing with the church then you need
to do the steps a to e those steps David
R you have to basically say you've been
a lying about everything that I'm
telling the truth about and making a
public announcement like that like I'd
have to come on your show and say I'm
lying and I haven't lied about anything
sure also I would have to go back into
Scientology and pay a lot of money for
counseling and it's like security-type
counseling like a lie detector and then
I have to retrain everything I did in
Scientology and I don't want to be a
Scientologist anymore after what they
did to my children I can't be on that
organization Laura you mentioned your
birth religion so to speak your your
baptism religion is Lutheran I'm curious
did you ever when you were in the Church
of Scientology did you literally believe
their teachings and the reason I asked
is I'm currently working my way through
Jeff Quinn's great book on the People's
Temple of course Jim Jones which led to
900 people literally drinking the
kool-aid and dying in Guyana and in the
1970s and a lot of that book exposes
that there were followers of Jim Jones
who did not really believe the religious
teachings but saw that for example the
social mission of his church or cult or
call it what you will was a positive one
or that membership was good for people
it kept kids out of trouble whatever so
my question to you is did you adhere to
the religious beliefs of the Church of
Scientology
I am I did not because I was baptized
Luther and I believed in God and my
husband the children's father didn't
believe in God and so that was hard for
us but I had that really good background
and I also didn't believe a lot of
things I would question them and get in
trouble for them and I didn't do the
higher levels of Scientology where I
think they teach you know things that I
didn't learn I didn't know I didn't go
past the state of clear high so I did
the lower level of Scientology so I
wouldn't know what those beliefs are
Lori in your book you talk about being
an FBI source when the FBI was
investigating Scientology about eight
years ago for possible human trafficking
through the Sea Org which is sort of the
leadership or management structure of
Scientology if it's okay with you I'd
love to learn a little bit about that
and my sort of initial question would be
how did the FBI initially get in touch
with you or how did you become in
contact with the FBI they found out
through a mutual friend that my son was
in the see organization during that
human trafficking investigation
and they wanted to come down and
interview me what happened with my son
they found out that the Church of
Scientology made my son sign a three
million dollar gag contract and they
definitely wanted to interview me and my
son because he was only 17 II was a
minor at that time so they came to my
office and interviewed me what happened
when Jeremy was in the see organization
they tried the interview Jeremy but
unfortunately I guess the church found
out and and Jeremy was nowhere to be
located and she couldn't believe that
she couldn't find him so she being the
FBI agent that you were working with and
she also interviewed my mom and a friend
that I I can't say who that is Lori were
you already out of the church in 2010
when the FBI came to you yes I I was out
they came in 2011 I resigned in August
2010 and after I went and saw Marty
Rathbun the first time in December 2010
the FBI started working with
around February 2011 so they were they
were working with me when I told them I
was gonna go see Marty the second time
and the day that the squirrel Buster's
arrived I was in Texas
seeing Marty I was the first one that
brought them I she told me to call her
if the FBI agent told me to call her if
there was anything you know that I
needed a report and she answered right
away when when John Islander and Mark
were like part of the squirrel Buster's
were there so for people who don't know
the squirrel Buster's are this sort of
goon squad that Scientology sends around
either to intimidate people to scare
them in in your case you were down in
Texas near Marty Rathbun's place who
we've also interviewed on the program
and they they showed up there
effectively right and I called her and
she told me to do a police report right
away which we did talk to me about what
what is in because to me when I hear
about what Scientology allegedly does it
seems that it's not just child
trafficking that the FBI would be
interested in so can you talk a little
bit about what sorts of things did the
FBI ask you about they they asked me
mainly about Jeremy his schooling
you know how much schooling he had they
broke the sea organization broke the
minor consent form where he was supposed
to have regular schooling and he only
had like five days they really wanted to
talk about you know why did I know
anything why they made him sign the
three million dollar gag contract to not
pick out they wanted to know why he was
off the base the C organization they
have a base a place where they are he
was off the base when he wanted to leave
for two weeks and he was kept away
without any guardian and they wanted to
go over that and they also wanted to go
over why I was threatened in the parking
lot by John mallinger he's a
Scientologist the day after I got back
from Marty's so they basically were
interested in my story the fair game
that Scientology does which means
they're going to do whatever they can do
to shut up a person speaking out and my
so that's they were interested in my
what happened with me and Dad the
recruiting of my children when I was not
at a good point I just got home from the
hospital they tried to recruit my 15
year old son then my daughter was
recruited in the Sea Org
and said goodbye to me when I was in the
hospital I mean you just don't do that
so they were really interested and and
that part of what happened with my story
do you continue to be harassed by
members of the church and scientist i
ontology are they currently do they
still put you under surveillance of any
kind um
the latest thing they did no because I
haven't gone to Texas in the last four
years if I go to Texas then yes you know
black SUV cars will follow me they'll be
at the hotel they'll stare at me don't
worry my kids so that's what happens
four years ago the only thing that's
happened is my book came out on Kindle
on April 2nd and they put a video of my
kids on and I just saw that I don't know
but it's on there on their site and I
saw that same video two years ago on
Good Morning America when I was on but I
only saw a part of it they put the full
thing in on the same day that my Kindle
book was out they put it up on their
site what's our what's your do you are
what if options.exists for reconnecting
with your kids is it basically at this
point up to them in the sense that
there's nothing doesn't sound like
there's anything physically stopping
them from seeing you but that the Church
of Scientology warns them about where
you're where you're going to be and it
seems that they've been sort of
successfully brainwashed into not
wanting to see you that's true I think
that the best thing is if they read my
book they see the truth they will see
how hard I've been fighting to them that
I tried to work internally with the
church that didn't get me anywhere and
they can see me but then they will get
kicked out of Scientology and so that's
that's there you know they just can't
see their mom they're gonna lose what
they believe in and actually David I
don't even know if they believe in it
anymore they might be scared I have no
idea I wish I could
talk to them what are their ages
currently Jeremy is gonna be 25 in June
and Jessica is gonna be 28 in August and
they just have I watched this video and
they have old information they have
information from a long time ago I don't
think the church tells them anything
that's new or how hard I'm trying to
reconnect with my children and I mean
even working internally I've written
them I send them presents I try to call
I'm blocked in always to reach them and
my son is so mad that I go to the media
I wish I could just call him privately
or talk to him face-to-face without
anybody interfering but Scientology
prevents me from doing that are you
mentioned that their father was not
religious or is he involved with
Scientology currently and are they in
touch with him oh very mixed oh yes he
is still active in Scientology Wow the
book is called a mother's heartbreak how
Scientology destroyed my family
Lori Hudson thanks again for talking to
me and really you know only the best the
best to you in the future of this
horrible situation thanks a lot David
thanks for having me on and I'm just
gonna stay strong and keep fighting and
educate other families what they do how
destructive they are to families if one
member doesn't agree with what they want
to do with your children and it's wrong
I just wanted mine to be in school and I
want to educate others so that's why I
did my book and I hope my kids read it
because I think they'll give me a call
if they read my book